the alt-right short for the alternative
right
sees itself as an important righteous
organic movement on the internet they
say that their goals
essentially are to combat feminism
islam political correctness to protect
the borders of white nations
in general they want to preserve white
culture
whatever that means and or western
culture
whatever that means and they want to
empower populist
authoritarian government leaders that
are willing to carry out
these goals corporate media has largely
ignored the alt-right
of course until recently when hillary
clinton mentioned it in a campaign
speech against donald trump
all key tenants making up the emerging
racist
ideology known as the alt right
but anyone who actively participates in
or just observes political discourse on
the internet
especially on youtube blogs and message
boards has been well aware of the
alt-right for quite some time
the alt-right is basically a combination
of conservatism white nationalism
and anti-interventionism combined with
the internet which is its crucial
ingredient
memes trolling campaigns and attempts at
intellectualism via
photoshop and different internet isms as
well as affinities for outlets like
breitbart
and often even more extreme websites
like the daily stormer and the right
stuff blog the alt-right hopes to be a
new
sort of revolutionary movement even
though it's mostly just derivative of
other movements
but in reality the only thing that makes
the alt-right novel or noteworthy
is the relationship with the internet
and troll culture
progressives have distaste for the
alt-right for obvious reasons their
nativist
xenophobic white nationalist tendencies
their love for what they call
traditional white values and their
bigotry towards
women muslims and a variety of other
groups libertarians can't stand the
alt-right because of their blind
anti-immigration dogma their social
conservatism
their populist empowerment of the state
and their appeal to economic
protectionism
and establishment conservatives see the
alt-right as a threat to conservatism
itself
because the alt-right is too blatant and
straightforward with their misogyny and
racism and because the alt-right is
non-interventionist
they're not necessarily christian and
because alt-righters are almost always
anti-semitic and anti-israel
the alt-right coalesced around u.s
republican presidential candidate donald
trump during the 2016 election
because of trump's carefree willingness
to candidly express his disrespect for
women
latinos black people and muslims and
because of his far
right-wing policy proposals on
immigration
labor issues social issues civil
liberties
the environment you name it trump has
said he doesn't know
anything about the alt-right so trump is
either lying
or he really is completely ignorant
about a significant
sect of his supporters would either
proposition really surprise
anyone even though most of trump
supporters are low education
low-income blue-collar voters with no
involvement with internet culture
and even though donald trump has said he
doesn't understand what the alt-right is
the alt-right internet troll community
has adopted donald trump
as a hero the alt-right is a mostly
american movement and the alt-right is
difficult to nail down
and characterize as an ideology because
it is so amorphous it can be defined in
a variety of ways both by
insiders and outsiders some people who
call themselves alt-right
identify just as racists some are
misogynists some are
just anti-semites many self-identify
themselves as
all of the above and others take issue
with being labeled as
one or any of the above so the alt-right
works together
throwing memes at people and using
cliche catchphrases online
but sometimes it doesn't even seem like
they are exactly sure what it means to
be alt-right
despite their lack of coherence as a
movement there are definitely
a number of values and buzz concepts
that often bring
these people together including white
culturalism
again whatever that means
anti-multiculturalism
nativism and anti-immigration sentiment
anti-foreign interventionism
anti-semitism
men's rights activism and gamergate
which among
the alt-right is often seen as a very
serious
and important movement although the
phenomenon of the alt-right is so
loosely defined
and has taken many shapes over time most
people say that the movement originally
began developing during the bush
administration
as a reaction to traditional
conservatism neo-conservatism as well as
the republican party
a lot of alt-righters say that their
philosophy is derived from
paleo conservatism giving credit to
people like pat buchanan
sam francis and joe sobrin but the
alt-right as a vague
mass collection of online posters
definitely has its roots in the
sensationalist excitement around ron
paul's 2008 and 2012 runs for president
which eventually devolved to become more
socially conservative and
bigoted and the alt-right definitely
began to pick up momentum during the
obama administration in reaction to a
black and left-of-center
president the creation of the alt-right
is usually attributed to a blogger and
podcaster
named richard spencer spencer is a white
supremacist
who founded the website called
alternative right in 2010
where the alt-right got its name
milo yiannopoulos the current beloved
poster boy of the alt-right who is in
essence single-handedly responsible for
bringing the alt-right to mainstream
awareness via breitbart and other media
appearances
has plenty of times said that he does
not even consider himself to be part of
the alt-right
this as well as the fact that he's a
half-jewish and gay man
acting as the prophet of an anti-semitic
and homophobic
supposed ideology speaks to both the
gimmicky performance art style of milo's
persona
as well as the lack of coherence that
the alt-right has as a movement
people who identify as alt-right are
almost universally biased against both
muslims
and jews but like i said alt-writers are
not necessarily christians across the
board
many are actually atheists but a
prevalent theme among them is their
fondness for the idea of what they like
to think of as
christian values which is another one of
these concepts that's hard to pin down
as a value system but it can probably be
best described
as an adherence to social conservatism
but interestingly at the same time
despite their love for right-wing
christianity's influence on the west
most within the alt-right embrace the
notion of evolution and many of them
adulterate the theory of evolution to
the point of using it to justify racism
claiming that there are human races or
sub-species
that sometimes are smarter more moral or
better than others
and of course they see white non-jews as
being the best
and they use non-scientific quackery to
come to these conclusions again
obviously there's nothing new or
interesting about these ideas there's
just a new loud group on the internet
called the alt-right that's touting this
outdated nonsense
the one and only redeeming quality of
the alt-right
is their commitment against political
correctness and identity politics to the
extent that it's destructive
i'm actively looking for a silver lining
here and this is at least
something we've talked on the show about
this plenty of times about how
authoritarian leftism
would some refer to as the regressive
left can be totally counterproductive in
how it stifles conversation about a
number of things
whether it be race islam feminism
but this is what i truly find to be most
ironic and hypocritical about the
alt-right
how they try to use political
correctness and identity politics
with respect to white people and men
people in the alt-right go around saying
that women
and ethnic minorities and religious
minorities rely
too much on acting as victims and trying
to censor discourse
but then the alt-right hilariously just
turns around
and moans about how badly whites and
males
are victimized and how important white
identity is how important
male identity is and they aggressively
attack
and shun those who disagree with them
about these things
they are so perfectly guilty of what
they constantly accuse
other groups of doing in terms of
identity politics political correctness
playing the victim card and they often
go as far
as to talk about white genocide
so maybe you're on the alt-right and
you're thinking well every other group
acts like a victim and celebrates their
identity
isn't it time for white people and men
to do the same doesn't that just level
the playing field
but that is exactly what the alt-right
criticizes
groups like women and minorities for
doing themselves
besides are men and white people the
real victims in this country
or in the world the attitude of the
alt-right is a prime example of identity
politics if there ever was one
centered around white non-jewish male
tribalism
another important thing to remember is
that the alt-right only has an identity
because of their commonality
as trolls they claim to be a unified
movement but they are as amorphous as
any other
trivial set of collective activities on
the internet
they derive their legitimacy from their
common goal of trying to offend and get
a rise out of people are
any other serious ideological movements
centered around
indecency for the sake of indecency for
the most part
the only thing that gives alt-right
internet foot soldiers any power
at all is their anonymity and their
unoriginal reliance
on sharing things like animated gifs and
tired terms and slogans
it is a textbook example of groupthink
the alt-right as a whole is a failed
homemade attempt to rebrand and
legitimize white supremacy
misogyny and anti-semitism with a tech
savviness twist
through the mindless celebration of
infantile trolling the reposting of
plagiarized memes
the copy and pasting of pepe the frog
and habits like the mindlessly
gratuitous use of the word cuck
it doesn't make them clever it doesn't
make them thinkers
for example look below this video
at the kids who have just pitifully
reproduced
asinine memes phrases and concepts
that they've learned or outright copied
from other people
they have nothing to say they have no
intellectual arguments they are sheep
and they pretend that their unorganized
allegiance to others who similarly
create
outrage is something that gives them
validity
as if it makes them witty it is a
cop-out put aside the bankruptcy of
their so-called philosophies
and just look at their tactics the way
they communicate
the way that they relay ideas to one
another
and to people with whom they disagree
there's no mistaking them
they are the most anti-intellectual
unimaginative and
easily identifiable group of drones on
the internet